trois listes de gauche sont proposés à
mantes la jolie pour l'élection
municipale partielle d'abord une
candidature rassemble la france
insoumise europe ecologie les verts et
le parti socialiste une équipe de gauche
mené par guillaume quévarec
objectif défendre un projet focaliser
sur trois priorités la jeunesse le
commerce et l'emploi puis le cadre de
vie et l'environnement alors tout de
suite on fait un audit sur les comptes
de la ville parce que malheureusement on
a un peu des doutes sur la sincérité des
comptes et l'état des finances ont fait
aussi un audit sur tous les programmes
immobiliers parce qu'on en a marre on
veut pas que cette ville ressemble à
quelque chose d'archivés tony's et donc
on travaille dessus et après on met le
paquet sur l'éducation donc on mettra en
place dès la rentrée de septembre des
études dirigées dans toutes les écoles
et on entame un programme de rénovation
ambitieux en termes de rénovation
notamment énergétiques des écoles et
donner davantage de moyens et dernier
point c'est le cadre de vie donc là
dessus il insiste beaucoup c'est à dire
qu'on veut développer les parties
circulations douces notamment vélo on
veut développer les espaces verts les
lieux où les habitants pourrait planter
les derniers points pour vous qui est
important c'est de réassocier les
habitants et les associations la prise
de décision la gauche ne sera pas
totalement unie le communiste marc
jammet repart pour un nouveau scrutin ce
sera sa dixième participation à une
élection membres de l'opposition
municipale il défend notamment un projet
social avec une limitation des
opérations d'urbanisme et un meilleur
accès aux soins là sur les projets
d'urbanisme c'est dès le lendemain mon
élection de son commerce il est monté le
veulent c'est de suspendre immédiatement
toutes les opérations d'urbanisme qui
sont en cours et se dire ben on n'est
pas six mois près et on va engager alors
il ya le référendum est au milieu et à
bord la concertation et comment on fait
pour concerter les gens
de les inviter à différentes choses et
de monter des projets alternatifs nous
ce que nous proposons c'est de salariés
les médecins qui le veulent et d'aller
les chercher avec un médecin référant
salariés
qui s'occupera lui d'aller voir dans les
facs de médecine fallait aller voir
d'aller proposer aux internes qui
sortent des facs de médecine horizons
mais nous on est d'accord pour vous
salariés son montage joli troisième
candidature à gauche sur l'échiquier
politique la liste de lutte ouvrière
mené par thierry gonot ouvrier à l'usiné
renault de flins il sera le porte parole
pour défendre le camp des travailleurs
de mantes-la-jolie une liste composée
majoritairement d'employés d'ouvriers
mentez et mantaise premier tour prévue
le 15 mai prochain pour renouveler le
conseil municipal de mantes la jolie